all I remember was it was a minute
something into the game and Cooley build
called a Mark or something he was going
to kick the bone off so I'm going to
charge this down and then I took off and
then I stopped I was like I'm not going
to get there and that's all I remembered
kick from Lachlan found some space
[Applause]
that's all I remembered and then I got
up
and I apparently I I went to go the
wrong way so I ran back to backfield and
I remember asking Alby matthewson I was
like man what happened I thought I got
like a shoulder or need is like the ball
hit you in the face and I was like shut
up so I turned around the Rodney and I
go what happened he was like the ball
hit you in the face and I was like what
oh God
have a look at this limbo action oh